une nouvelle étude publiée dans le
british medical journal soulève le doute
sur les bienfaits des programmes de
dépistage des cancers pourquoi parce que
selon les chercheurs les programmes de
dépistage ne permettrait pas de réduire
la mortalité dans la population en
général
mont saint michel on croit tous au
programme de dépistage alors que nous
dit cette étude précisément les auteurs
de l'étude disent qu'il ne faut pas
cesser ces programmes là mais il faut
regarder ce à la lumière de ce que la
science dit en étudiant les résultats de
tous ces programmes la regardons
ensemble
alors oui effectivement aucune réduction
globale de la mortalité
ils ont des hypothèses si on regarde le
positif et négatif c'est que oui à une
réduction de la mortalité
la mortalité spécifique dans les cancers
visé mais souvent on voit une
augmentation de la mortalité liée au
dépistage lui même alors ce que les
auteurs disent pourquoi dépenser des
millions dans ses programmes quand on ne
change pas la mortalité de façon globale
dans la population
alors si le dépistage lui même qui
causeraient des mortalités comment
comment est ce que c'est possible
bon alors céline quand on dépiste des
millions de personnes ils passent tous
ce test de dépistage l'a souvent il y
avait des artefacts qui ont des
conséquences sur la santé de ces gens-là
regardons ensemble alors souvent on a
des faux positifs
qu'est ce que c'est que alors là on peut
voir une tumeur dans une radiographie
croire que c'est une tumeur mais en fait
ce n'est pas une tumeur on appelle ça un
faux positif en surdiagnostic en est on
sûr prétend beaucoup de personnes on
arrive souvent à beaucoup de
complications et à des décès inutiles à
cause des traitements inutiles qu'on
leur a donné
alors que dit la recherche sur les
cancers les plus répandus leur parle du
cancer de la prostate pour les hommes
cancer du sein pour les femmes
bon alors il ya une grande méta analyse
qui est fait par un groupe qui s'appelle
le cac win collaborative
alors ils ont regardé à la fois le
cancer la prostate dont ça c'est un test
sanguin en mesure une enzyme la sp et
chez les femmes
ben si l'oeuf la fameuse mammographies
pour les femmes de 50 ans et plus on ne
voit pas d'amélioration dans la
mortalité
on n'arrive pas à sauver ces gens là de
ces cancers là dans l'absolu c'est quand
même surprenant mais quand même on doit
pas arrêter
dépistage non absolument pas alors les
auteurs parlent d'une médecine plus
personnalisée de bien informer le
patient de ce que c'est et dans un
deuxième temps de voir si le risque en
vaut la peine
alors là la solution c'est d'aller vers
un dépistage beaucoup plus individualisé
donc parler plus à son médecin c'est ça
oui on a des antécédents etc
oui absolument merci beaucoup séduit